what's going on people today we're about
to break down episode 21 of attack on
time season 4 in which aaron begins the
rumbling and the true origin of the nine
titans was finally revealed
in this video i'll be explaining
everything you need to know including
the hidden details about ymir's life and
the real reason why she chose to help
aaron destroy the world before we dive
into it i know that some of you watching
might be new to the channel so if you
want to see breakdowns like this every
week then be sure to smash that sub
button and drop a like if you like the
video
okay so in the last episode zeke tried
to convince his brother to join him in
the euthanization plan by taking them
into grisha's memories he hoped this
would make aaron realize that he'd been
manipulated by their dad but as it turns
out their dad was the one being
manipulated by aaron the whole time
thanks to the secret ability of the
attack titan aaron was able to send
grisham memories from the future and
these future memories convinced their
dad to murder the royal family in this
new episode things continue directly on
from this with grisha transforming into
a shifter and giving fida a beatdown not
to mention squishing the rices with his
bare hands
following that we eventually return to
the main area of the past dimension
where the oldest egg brother is still
trying to process what just happened
based on everything he just saw zeke
realizes that their dad only did what he
did because he was shown specific
memories from the future that aaron had
chosen to send back
this manipulation is why grisha ate the
founder despite knowing he would never
be able to use his power and it's why he
entrusted everything to his son leading
us to where we are now
i explained this next part in my last
video but just in case you didn't see
that aaron goes on to confirm that four
years ago when he kissed his story his
hand he saw the same memories his dad
saw in the rice chapel
among other things it's implied that
this included memories of the rumbling
which was sent to their dad by a version
of aaron even further in the future as a
result for the last four years he's
known this destruction was destined to
happen and ever since he went to mali
he's been doing the necessary things to
arrive at this end point
in this scene however zeke decides to
try and take back control of the
situation as he orders emir to sterilize
every elden in the world
because she's a slave to the royal
bloodline yami begins to follow his
command without a second thought and
she'll be able to actually do it when
she reaches the coordinate zeke then
correctly points out that although aaron
might have seen glimpses of the future
he obviously hasn't seen everything and
this is proven by the fact that at
various moments along the way he didn't
know certain things would go against him
anyway azimir edges nearer to the
coordinator aaron desperately tries to
bait free from the chains around each of
his wrists these chains are pretty much
unbreakable considering they were made
by the founder herself but he knows that
if he doesn't escape now then the aldean
race doesn't have a future that's
exactly why he was so desperate to reach
her and after struggling for a while he
pulls away with so much force that both
of his thumbs were ripped off
after the opening the anime then
suddenly flashes back around 10 years
earlier to a moment between frieda and
historia as we already know freda would
sometimes visit historia during her
childhood and was the person that taught
her how to read and write and in this
particular clip they were reading about
a character who was based on yamir fritz
we can tell from the devil on the left
page that this book isn't yamir's real
backstory but instead it's one of the
many fairy tales inspired by her over
the centuries kruger said back in season
3 that anyone can become a god or a
devil as long as people believe it and
in emir's case she was considered a god
by the alien empire while also being
viewed as a pawn of the devil by the
malians
as we're about to see the truth was a
lot more complicated than that because
for a start she was just a regular girl
who lived peacefully in this village
around 2000 years ago
the anime briefly shows her going about
her daily life getting water from the
well but unfortunately this was the day
her village was invaded by a violent
tribune as the eldians these aliens
proceeded to burn everything to the
ground and kill many of the locals
including this woman who was implied to
be yamir's relative she was then
captured as a slave alongside anyone
else who wasn't killed and they all had
their tongues cut out to stop them from
speaking hence why later on they only
communicate using hand gestures
one small detail is that ymir continued
the habit of not speaking even after she
gained titan powers which is interesting
because you know with these shifter
abilities her tongue definitely would
have grown back
at this early stage in the timeline
though she was still just a regular
person and every day the slaves were
forced to carry out basic tasks like
carrying water or looking after the pigs
if we pause for a second on this
screenshot you'll notice that yamir was
fascinated by this elden couple who were
getting married since the love these two
had for each other was something that
ymir wanted for herself in a similar way
to how eren was yearning for freedom or
how zeke was yelling for fatherly
affection what yamir wanted was to be
loved hence why she always did things to
try and please other people this ties
into what frida said about how the girl
in the book was a kind person who helped
others but in reality this desire to
help others is what screwed up yamir's
life more than it already was
on one specific occasion a slave allowed
a pick to escape and the king of the
aldians wanted to find the person
responsible he threatened to gouge out
an eye from every single one of them
unless someone confessed and it didn't
take long for them to all point the
finger at yumir while it's not specified
whether she really did it or not her
options were still pretty limited in
this situation and by accepting
responsibility it meant less people
would suffer
following her confession the king
declared that she was free to go and she
was sent into the forest while these
eldian soldiers hunted her for fun with
yamir continuing to lose blood this
honestly should have been the end but as
she continued to stumble forward her
blood spilled on this flower in attack
on titan this type of flowers become a
symbol for being reborn since every time
it appears someone gets a second chance
at life the first time we saw it was
when zeke was on the brink of death only
to be given a brand new body the second
time we saw it was here just before a
wounded emir gains the power of the
titans and the third time we see it is
later on when after death her spirit is
reborn in the past dimension
anyhow in this sequence she looks up to
see this unbelievable tree towering
above all the others and she walks into
it because she was still trying to find
a place to hide
on the inside she then slips down into a
body of water and as she begins to drown
this mysterious creature appears out of
nowhere
in the last season kruger referred to
this creature as the source of all
living matter but whatever it is its
design is inspired by the hallucigenia
for some unknown reason this version of
the creature had the ability to titanize
things hence why the tree it lived in
was so large and by latching onto yamir
spine it turned her into the first ever
founding titan
when it comes to size her shifter easily
surpasses the colossal and every other
titan until this episode and its design
was definitely more bony compared to
what we're used to seeing
in the past we've seen that spawner
fluid is so important when it comes to
passing down shifter abilities or
creating the time transformation serum
and now we know it's because the power
of the titans itself literally
originates from this spinal connection
moving on with her new shifted abilities
you'd think someone in yemen's position
would want to get revenge on the alien
tribe and stamp them all to pieces but
instead she returned to serve under the
king as baffling as this seems it does
make sense for her character since her
titan powers made her useful to him
which in turn brought her closer to the
love she was desperate to receive
this scene takes place many years after
she first became a titan and by then
he'd been using her in various ways to
expand the tribe resulting in them now
being a lot richer although it should be
obvious to everyone that he never
actually loved ymir from her point of
view this was the closest thing she was
going to get and in her own messed up
way she did love the king
her undying loyalty is why he was more
than happy to give her three children
over the years and these kids were
called mario rose and cena if those
names sound familiar is because nearly 2
000 years later the 145th aldian king
decided to name the three wolves on
paradise after them
while we're on the topic of names in
this episode the first ldn king refers
to himself as fritz which is the true
name of the royal bloodline that exists
to this day although the name was
changed to rice when they arrived on
paradise the fact remains that all
raw-blooded individuals are members of
the fris family and it's because of
their connection to him that yamir obeys
those with royal blood we'll talk more
about the topic of blood in a second but
first we've got a few clips of the
original founding titan on the
battlefield as she was about to wipe out
a wave of malian soldiers back in these
days enemy nations had nothing that
could possibly fight back against the
titan and because of that yamiya's
presence made the eldian empire quite
literally unbeatable thanks to her they
were able to easily defeat marley and
presumably any other nation they wanted
to enabling fritz to keep evolving their
empire in terms of manpower and
infrastructure
by this time 13 years had now passed
since she first gained the power of the
titans and despite all the different
ways fritz had used and abused her she
still did love him in a twisted way
on one occasion as the king was
addressing his soldiers at least one of
his men had been plotting to assassinate
him since someone had buried the spear
in the ground beforehand due to that
this soldier was able to whip it out
before anyone could stop him and he
threw it hard enough to instantly kill
the king or at least it would have
killed him if ymir didn't make herself a
human shield
although her injury through the heart
was really bad we have still seen
shifters come back from worse but
injuries like this only heal if the
person has the will to live as we can
see here yamir's will to live vanish
when she looked up at king fritz because
in this moment he basically told her to
get over it and get back to work
until he said that her eyes were
actually open but after hearing his
final orders that's when she no longer
had the will to carry on as she closed
her eyes this flower from before
flickers on screen and in a cruel twist
of fate her spirit is then reborn in the
past dimension in this new reality ymir
took on the same appearance she had when
she was a young slave and as a slave she
would fulfill fritz's final orders
for the next two millennia whenever one
of her descendants would call in the
power of the titans ymir would
personally be in this dimension molding
each shifter by hand it's important to
remember that time also passes
differently in parts so although these
shifters always look like they're being
created straight away in reality it must
have felt like months or even years
every single time she had to make one
back in the real world king fritz had
her dead body chopped up for their
daughters to eat in a scene that was
foreshadowed all the way back in the end
credits for season 2.
at this time in history no shifter had
ever been passed from one person to
another so the king was basically trying
anything he could to make sure ymir's
power didn't disappear no matter how
disgusting it might be
as the only humans with yamir's blood in
their veins mario rose and cena were the
only ones capable of inheriting these
shifter abilities and by eating their
mother's spine yumi's titan was divided
between the three of them this is
different to the present day where
normally one person eats one shifter but
because he means daughters ate her spine
together while in their human form this
is apparently the secret to dividing
titan powers
gradually the three titans that the
daughters possess grew into the
nightmare today and in this shot we got
a brief look at some of the first
iterations of these titans to exist
during the king's dying speech to his
daughters he made it pretty clear that
he didn't want this age of the titans to
end which by extension means that yamir
would never be free
her strange love for him kept her bound
to the past dimension for nearly 2 000
years and in all that time she never
tried defying him until aaron arrived as
he catches up with her he reminds ymir
that she doesn't need to serve anyone
and that she's just a person who's
essentially lost her true self that's
why he lets her know that it's her
choice what to do next she can either
continue to stay here and work like she
always has or she can help him destroy
the world that always treated her so
badly
ultimately she does decide to go with
aaron instead of zeke making this the
first time she'd ever disobeyed someone
of royal blood and if we pause for a
second i'm gonna explain why
point number one is that zeke basically
thought of yamir in the same way king
fritz did in that he thought of her as a
slave lacking free will that he could
use for his own purposes
even until the end he never acknowledged
her as a real human being whereas from
the start aaron saw her as a person and
couldn't believe that she'd been here
alone this whole time he understood that
it must have been agony to be in this
realm obeying orders for thousands of
years and unlike zeke he tried to offer
her a choice rather than simply viewing
her as a tool
point number two is that yamir was
clearly waiting for someone to free her
from this pain because after serving
other people her whole life i guess she
had to be reminded that it was okay to
exercise her own free will
from her point of view lashing out of
the world is clearly more appealing than
spending another hundred years trapped
in the past dimension which is what
would inevitably happen if she follows
zeke's euthanization plan
now before we move on to the amazing
reveal of eren's founding titan there
were a few bits of trivia that i thought
were worth mentioning to begin the name
of this episode is from you 2 000 years
ago which is a reference to the first
episode of attack on titan which was
called to you 2 000 years from now
the names of these titles make it sound
like kimia sent something to aaron in
the first episode which he then received
in this episode and one interpretation
is that it's referring to the memories
of her life story which he likely
received when they made contact
alternatively it could be referring to
the power she gave him to start the
rumbling or it might simply be referring
to the fact that she's been waiting for
2000 years for someone like him to
arrive
next up earlier in the episode frida
mentioned his story that she should be a
ladylike person like the girl in the
book and this is what directly led to
her overly kind personality that we saw
in the first couple seasons
the girl in the book was called krista
which is the same fake name that
historia used when she joined the cadets
and it wasn't until she met a titan
shifter called yamir that she gained the
courage to act as her true self
finally the last thing to point out is
that the concepts in this episode are
heavily derived from norse mythology
whether it be the world tree ragnarok
the nine titans corresponding with the
nine realms or the fact that ymir is the
name of the first giant in both
universes the connection likely runs
even deeper than just this however my
understanding of norse mythology is
limited to my unfinished playthrough of
god of war and the mcu for that reason i
really can't go into any more detail but
i'm sure there is someone out there who
knows all about this stuff
anyhow moving on to the rest of the
episode in the real world only a second
had passed since gabby blew off aaron's
head
in this moment here the source of all
living matter jumps out of his spine to
connect with his brain granting him the
true power of the founding titan thanks
to yumi's blessing almost immediately
following this the first thing he does
is crumble all the hardening on parodies
collapsing the walls that have been
there for over a century as some of the
hardening falls down in gabi's direction
eren begins his weird transformation
which was unusual for a few reasons
not only is his new titan significantly
larger and more bony than any titan in
history but it also takes on a similar
shape to the hallucigenia its bizarre
appearance is the result of aaron
transforming while in this condition
cause the source of all of mata had no
choice but to improvise and make a new
body based on his own image
if aaron had made contact with zeke when
his body was whole then i can guarantee
you this sent to be titan never would
have happened but because of what gabby
did this is now the consequence
the titans in the war then begin to
march which is what armin always
predicted that eren would do although
what he wasn't expecting was the amount
of titans that would be set free earlier
in the season the military was planning
to do a small rumbling using only the
titans in shiganjina so armin couldn't
understand why the rest of the wars were
being crumbled as well his answer came
seconds later when aaron used the
coordinate in one of the most epic waves
we've seen as he was able to send a
telepathy message to every single elden
on the planet all of yamir subjects were
mentally taken to the past dimension
regardless of where they were in the
real world and the cameos include
annie's dad historia and all of the
warriors
after introducing himself over the
speaker system aaron pretty much spells
out why he wants to wipe out life
outside the walls and to summarize it
for this video his goal is to protect
the people of parodies by eliminating
all their enemies outside the island
from his point of view the outside
world's hatred of ld has grown over the
years and he realized that there was no
peaceful way of stopping this cycle of
hatred
as long as there are aldians then there
were always going to be those people who
want to destroy them for being devils
and so in his mind putting an end to
everything is the only way to save the
people he cares about a large part of
his motivation during the time skip was
to make sure that historia and the rest
of his friends didn't need to inherit
any shifters since he wanted all of them
to live long lives by stopping the cycle
of hatred he will accomplish that goal
but the obvious downside is that
billions of people have to die in the
process
the episode ends with this ugly black
and white shot of aaron's head and this
is what he looks like on the inside of
this giant skull
anyway people that was my breakdown for
episode 21 of attack on titan season 4
and if it helped to understand the
episode in any way then i'd appreciate
if you hit that sub button and let me
know your thoughts in the comments
thanks for watching as always and until
the next one peace out